In Ukraine, the government has set up this phone line. It's for soldiers to call-- Russian soldiers-- if they want to surrender.
在乌克兰，政府设立了一条电话热线。这是供士兵——俄罗斯士兵——如果他们想投降时拨打的。
[CONNECTING TONE]
[拨号音]
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
Ukraine's says over 3,500 soldiers have texted or called the number. One of my coworkers, Valerie Kipnis, has been looking into this hotline, and helpfully, speaks Russian. So what did they just say?
乌克兰方面称，已有超过3500名士兵发送短信或拨打了该号码。我的同事瓦莱丽·基普尼斯一直在调查这条热线，幸运的是，她会说俄语。那么他们刚才说了什么？
So they said, hello, to one another, and then the guy asked, is this Ukraine? And the guy on the hotline answered, yeah, this is Ukraine.
他们互相问候，然后那个人问，这是乌克兰吗？热线那边的人回答说，是的，这是乌克兰。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
And then, the soldier said, I got a text that if we wish to surrender, call this number.
然后，那个士兵说，我收到一条短信，说如果我们想投降，就打这个号码。
He got a text?
他收到了一条短信？
Yeah, people pass around the number on social media and Telegram. There's even a website for it. It's called Hochy-Zhit dot com.
是的，人们在社交媒体和Telegram上转发这个号码。甚至还有一个专门的网站，叫“我想活下去”网站（Hochy-Zhit.com）。
And that means--
那意思是——
"I want to live" dot com.
“我想活下去”网站。
That's very direct.
这非常直接。
Yeah. On it, it reads, "Servicemen of the Russian armed forces, do you notice that you're greeted not with flowers, but with fire and curses? Do you notice that your commanders run away first? Save your life, for yourself and your family. Stop fighting for other people's slogans. Contact us. Save your life."
是的。网站上写着：“俄罗斯武装部队的军人，你们注意到迎接你们的不是鲜花，而是炮火和诅咒吗？你们注意到你们的指挥官总是先逃跑吗？为了你自己和家人，拯救你的生命吧。别再为别人的口号而战了。联系我们。拯救你的生命。”
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
OK, so what happens in this call?
好的，那通话里发生了什么？
One interesting thing is that the guy doesn't seem to know if he can actually believe them. He's questioning if he can trust them.
有趣的一点是，那个人似乎不知道是否真的可以相信他们。他在质疑自己能否信任他们。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
He's saying, you won't be cutting our balls off?
他说，你们不会把我们的蛋蛋割掉吧？
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
And then, the hotline guy answers, no, those are myths you guys are being fed. No one's going to be cutting anybody.
然后，热线那边的人回答说，不，那是你们被灌输的谣言。没有人会割掉谁的任何部位。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
Don't worry.
别担心。
Wait, but can I ask you, like, why would somebody who's calling this number-- like, why would they trust them?
等等，但我能问一下吗，比如，为什么拨打这个号码的人——他们为什么要信任对方？
Well, obviously, it's a scary decision, and they have to judge it for themselves. But on the website, it says, you know, we follow the Geneva Conventions for the treatment of prisoners of war. And they say they guarantee certain things-- three meals a day, medical service, legal support from international organizations, and regular communication with relatives.
嗯，显然这是一个可怕的决定，他们必须自己做出判断。但网站上说，我们遵守《日内瓦公约》中关于战俘待遇的规定。他们承诺保证一些事情——一日三餐、医疗服务、国际组织的法律援助，以及与亲属的定期联系。
What else happens in this call?
通话中还发生了什么？
Well, there's a bunch of stuff about, how does this actually work? Like, how do I surrender?
嗯，有很多关于“这到底是怎么运作的”内容？比如，我该如何投降？
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
Where should we come by? The soldier asks.
我们应该去哪里？士兵问。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
The hotline guy says, if you're fighting, then you're probably located in a certain region.
热线人员说，如果你在战斗，那么你可能就在某个特定区域。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
Well, yeah. And you'll come pick us up?
嗯，是的。你们会来接我们吗？
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
Yeah. We need to understand where you are and whether you really want to surrender. For that, I need your information, and then I'll contact you.
是的。我们需要了解你在哪里，以及你是否真的想投降。为此，我需要你的信息，然后我会联系你。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
And then, you can surrender, if you wish.
然后，如果你愿意，你就可以投降了。
Does the soldier sound nervous to you?
你觉得那个士兵听起来紧张吗？
Yeah. On the call, you can kind of hear him trying to make the decision of whether to do this or not.
是的。在通话中，你可以听到他似乎在努力做出是否要这样做的决定。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
We didn't even want to come here. We were ordered. Now, I'm thinking about what I can do. The guy in the hotline says, so, as I'm telling you, if you want to, you can surrender, and then return back home.
我们根本不想来这里。我们是奉命行事。现在，我在考虑我能做什么。热线的那个人说，正如我告诉你的，如果你想的话，你可以投降，然后回家。
Please understand there's a Geneva convention that says that a combatant has no criminal liability, so long as he did not commit war crimes, in which case, you'll be returned home through a prisoner swap.
请理解，《日内瓦公约》规定，战斗人员只要没有犯下战争罪，就不承担刑事责任，在这种情况下，你会通过战俘交换被送回家。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
The soldier says, "Understood."
士兵说：“明白了。”
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
Thank you.
谢谢。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
The hotline guy says, yeah, call any time.
热线的那个人说，好的，随时打电话。
OK, so then the guy just hung up?
好的，然后那个人就挂断了？
Yeah.
是的。
Do we have any idea, like, whether he went through with it?
我们有办法知道他是否真的去投降了吗？
No idea.
不知道。
Oh.
噢。
Yeah.
是的。
Were you able to find anybody who actually used the hotline, and then surrendered?
你能找到真正使用过这条热线并投降的人吗？
So I spent a lot of time trying to find someone who had done that, and I stumbled across an interview with a guy who tried. And he told his whole story.
我花了很多时间试图寻找这样做过的人，我偶然发现了一次采访，受访者尝试过。他讲述了他的整个故事。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
So this is the guy.
所以这就是那个人。
Tell me about him.
跟我说说他。
He's young, 22 years old, kind of lanky. He was studying to be a computer programmer, and then was drafted into the army last fall.
他很年轻，22岁，人有点瘦长。他本来在学计算机编程，去年秋天被征召入伍。
Because they have, like, mandatory military service in Russia, still.
因为在俄罗斯仍然有义务兵役制。
Yeah. Every Russian guy has to do it. And there, he was assigned to be a rifleman and an assistant grenade launcher.
是的。每个俄罗斯男人都必须服役。在那里，他被分配为步枪手和副掷弹筒手。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
But he had friends in Ukraine. And from the start of the invasion, he was very skeptical of the war.
但他有朋友在乌克兰。从入侵开始，他就对这场战争非常怀疑。
And is he part of the invasion?
他参与了入侵吗？
No, at least not right away. But he says he has a close friend who was sent into combat and dies the first day of the war.
没有，至少一开始没有。但他表示，他有一个亲密的朋友被派往战场，并在战争的第一天就阵亡了。
Oh, wow.
天哪。
Yeah. And then, he starts talking to his other friend, the only person he really trusts, who's in the army with him. And they start talking about, maybe we should surrender. Like, maybe we should leave.
是的。然后，他开始和他唯一真正信任的那个在部队里的朋友交谈。他们开始讨论，也许我们应该投降。也许我们应该离开。
And at first, they're on the same page. But then, the closer they get to the front line, the less on-board his friend starts to get.
起初，他们想法一致。但随着他们离前线越来越近，他朋友的立场开始动摇了。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
And one night, after he gets news of a successful counteroffensive in Kharkiv, he decides to go alone. He's actually in Russia. That's where he's based. And he says, after an eight-hour shift, he walks out of the barracks, heads west with a map and compass, and walks for two days.
一天晚上，在他得知哈尔科夫反攻成功的消息后，他决定独自行动。他当时实际上在俄罗斯境内。他说，八小时轮班结束后，他走出兵营，拿着地图和指南针向西走，走了两天。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
This seems so dangerous. Like, the Ukrainians could see him coming and just decide to shoot him.
这看起来太危险了。乌克兰人可能会看到他过来，然后直接决定开枪射杀他。
Yeah. Or the Russians could see him fleeing. And after walking, finally, he makes it to the border.
是的。或者俄罗斯人可能会看到他逃跑。在行走之后，他终于到达了边境。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
And that's when he calls the hotline. The interviewer asks him about it.
就在那时，他拨打了热线。采访者问了他相关的情况。
Wait, who is doing the interview?
等等，是谁在采访？
So it's one of these two Ukrainian YouTubers who seem to have some connection with the Ukrainian government.
是这两个乌克兰YouTuber中的一位，他们似乎与乌克兰政府有一些联系。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
The soldier says he heard about the hotline from friends living in Ukraine, and also, this girl, a good friend of his. The host asks, what's her name? She'll probably watch this.
那名士兵说，他是从住在乌克兰的朋友那里听说这条热线的，还有这个女孩，一个他的好朋友。主持人问，她叫什么名字？她可能会看这个视频。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
He says, her name is Anya.
他说，她叫安雅。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
He reaches the hotline over Telegram. They told him to make his way to a village in Ukraine, where Ukrainian servicemen would be waiting for him. He got his last bits of energy together and started to make his way over.
他通过Telegram联系上了热线。他们让他前往乌克兰的一个村庄，那里会有乌克兰士兵等着他。他集中了最后一点力气，开始向那边进发。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
When I got to where they told me to go, it was sunset, not totally dark yet.
当我到达他们告诉我的地方时，天色已晚，还没完全黑透。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
And I just looked at the village for a long time.
我看着那个村子看了很久。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
Truth be told, I was scared I wouldn't make it, that I'd just get shot. That was the scariest part.
老实说，我很害怕自己无法到达那里，害怕会被枪杀。那是最可怕的部分。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
And then, the interviewer interrupts. He says, seeing as you're here now, you didn't get shot. And he says, yeah, but I know what I look like in a Russian uniform. There could be an incident where I would get shot without any questions.
然后，采访者打断了他。他说，既然你现在在这儿，说明你没被枪杀。他说，是的，但我知道我穿着俄罗斯制服是什么样子。可能会发生我没问任何问题就被射杀的情况。
So what happens.
那后来发生了什么？
So once he gets there, he meets a Ukrainian woman and asks her for directions.
当他到达那里时，他遇到了一位乌克兰妇女，并向她问路。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
She says, my kids can walk you there. They're going to come back alive, right? And he swears that he won't hurt anyone. So the kids walk him to the school gymnasium.
她说，我的孩子可以带你去那里。他们能活着回来，对吧？他发誓他不会伤害任何人。于是孩子们带他去了学校体育馆。
He gives the boy his pocketknife as a "thank you." And then, he's in--
他把折叠刀送给那个男孩作为“感谢”。然后，他就进去了——
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
How many times were you beaten?
你被打了多少次？
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
Not once.
一次都没有。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
How about tortured?
那被折磨呢？
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
Never. In fact, they offered us candy and sweets. Though, I should point out, the UN has documented human rights abuses against Russian prisoners of war in Ukraine. They weren't reported to be systematic.
从来没有。事实上，他们还给了我们糖果和甜点。不过，我应该指出，联合国记录了乌克兰针对俄罗斯战俘的人权侵犯行为。据报道这些行为并非系统性的。
Yeah. Well, what about the fact that they're allowing video interviews with prisoners of war to go online?
是的。那么，他们允许战俘的视频采访上网这件事呢？
Yeah, that's potentially a violation of the Geneva Conventions. There are rules in there about not turning prisoners of war into subjects of public curiosity.
是的，这可能违反了《日内瓦公约》。公约中有规定，不得将战俘变成公众好奇的对象。
So then, after that, he's basically in a POW camp, like, waiting for a prisoner swap to go home?
所以在那之后，他基本上就在战俘营里，等着通过战俘交换回家？
I'm not sure he wants to go back. And I'm not sure what would happen to him if he did. He's given his full name on YouTube, admitting publicly he deserted the Russian army. Also, he says that he doesn't believe in Russia's version of the war. Like he says in the video, you're on your way to kill innocent people that are just defending their own country.
我不确定他想不想回去。我也不确定如果他回去了会发生什么。他在YouTube上给出了全名，公开承认自己从俄罗斯军队中开了小差。此外，他说他不相信俄罗斯版本的战争。就像他在视频里说的那样，你正要去杀害无辜的人，而这些人只是在保卫自己的国家。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
Then, when the interviewer asks him if he'd like to make a call home--
然后，当采访者问他是否想打个电话回家时——
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
He says, no, politely. His parents have different views on the war than him. Instead, he calls his friend, Anya, the one who told him about the hotline. There's a short clip of him on the phone.
他礼貌地拒绝了。他父母对战争的看法与他不同。相反，他打电话给了那个告诉他热线的朋友安雅。有一小段他在通话的片段。
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
He updates her on his status, and then says--
他向她更新了自己的近况，然后说——
[RUSSIAN SPEECH]
[俄语对话]
Tell me how you're doing. My life is such a mess right now.
告诉我你怎么样了。我的生活现在简直是一团糟。
The way Russia sees the war and the way Ukraine sees it are like two different realities. But you know, there are so many places where that kind of thing is true, where one reality bumps up against another. And people try to coax each other across the line from one side to the other.
俄罗斯看待战争的方式和乌克兰看待战争的方式就像两个不同的现实。但你知道，有很多地方都有这种情况，即一个现实与另一个现实发生碰撞。人们试图诱导对方跨越界限，从一边走到另一边。
But crossing over-- not that many people do it, because it's so hard to do. It seems so dangerous. Today, on our program, we have people trying to sweet-talk each other across that line, with reason and with guile and with whatever they got. It's such an act of faith in each other even to try-- kind of inspiring, really. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us, please.
但跨越的人——并不多，因为这太难了。看起来太危险了。今天在我们的节目中，我们有人们试图用理智、诡计和他们所拥有的一切，来劝说对方跨越那道界限。仅仅是尝试这种互相信任的行为——确实有点鼓舞人心。来自芝加哥WBEZ，《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act 1, Flies, Meet Honey. So this woman, Aubree, has been calling elections administrators all over Texas for nearly two years. And as a case study of people trying to coax others over to their side, it's not going too well.
第一幕，苍蝇与蜂蜜。这位叫奥布里的女士，两年来一直在给德克萨斯州各地的选举管理人员打电话。作为人们试图劝说他人站到自己一边的案例研究，进展并不太顺利。
She questions them, accuses them. There's one call I want to play a little bit of-- kind of, sums things up. At the beginning of the call, the official is very calm, saying things like--
她质疑他们，指控他们。有一段通话我想播一小段——算是总结了一下。通话开始时，官员非常冷静，说着类似的话——
Aubree, you brought up a lot of things, so I wanted to tackle them one by one.
奥布里，你提了很多问题，所以我想一个一个来解决。
But pretty quickly, Aubree is asking him about things that he can't comment on, because they're the subject of lawsuits. Lawyers have told them not to talk about them publicly. But Aubree-- she doesn't accept that. She keeps pushing.
但很快，奥布里就开始问他一些他无法评论的事情，因为它们是诉讼的主题。律师告诉他们不要公开谈论这些事情。但奥布里——她不接受。她不断逼问。
Your county attorneys-- they don't want you to give information to the voters?
你们的县检察官——他们不想让你向选民提供信息？
All I'm telling you is, I'm following their advice, Aubree. And I look forward to a time when I'm able to talk more freely about this.
我所能告诉你的是，我正在遵循他们的建议，奥布里。我期待着有朝一日能更自由地谈论这个问题。
So you're not able to talk freely about the issues in the elections, because one part of it has been filed with a court of law?
所以你不能自由地谈论选举中的问题，是因为其中一部分已经提交到了法院？
Aubree, did you not understand what I said earlier, when I said I'm not?
奥布里，我刚才说的话你没听懂吗，我说我不能？
I do not. Could you help me understand--
我没听懂。你能帮我理解一下吗——
I think I've spoken clearly and in English that I have, that I can't speak about this, because of the current and ongoing litigation.
我想我已经用英语表达得很清楚了，由于目前正在进行的诉讼，我不能谈论这件事。
As you can hear, this gets hotter and hotter. He's an elections administrator in a county in central Texas and has had years of Stop the Stealers now, questioning him like this. They flood elections offices with records requests. They sue.
正如你所听到的，火药味越来越浓。他是一位德克萨斯州中部的县选举管理员，现在已经忍受了多年的“停止窃选”抗议者这样质问他。他们用记录请求淹没选举办公室。他们起诉。
Before long in this call, Aubree is quoting Texas legal code that she believes mandates that all ballots in Texas should be pre-numbered sequentially, starting at one, which isn't done today, with computers counting votes. And the elections administrator snaps.
通话不久后，奥布里引用了她认为要求德克萨斯州所有选票必须从第一号开始预先编号的德州法律，而现在使用计算机计票并不这么做。选举管理员爆发了。
What else would you like to quote, chapter and verse incorrectly?
你还想引用哪一章哪一条的错误内容？
OK, sure. Sure. So you're sitting in violation of the state and national constitutions, because the--
好的，当然。当然。所以你违反了州和国家宪法，因为——
Incorrect. Wrong. Next.
不正确。错了。下一个。
Let me finish, sir. The Secretary of State does not have the authority to circumvent Texas election code, 52--
让我说完，先生。国务卿没有权力绕过德克萨斯州选举法第52条——
You're mistaken. You're mistaken.
你弄错了。你弄错了。
No, I'm not.
不，我没有。
I don't even have to let you finish. I can tell you right now, off the bat, you're mistaken. Next.
我甚至不需要让你说完。我现在就可以告诉你，一开始你就错了。下一个。
Can you tell me the election code that you can cite, that allows you to circumvent the 52.062 and 62.009?
你能告诉我你引用的允许你绕过52.062和62.009的选举法吗？
Request denied.
请求被拒绝。
You don't know it off the top of your head like I do? But you don't know the codes in the law off the top of your head?
你记不住它吗？但你记不住法律条文吗？
I don't.
我不记得。
OK. Do you-- have you read-- have you read the national--
好的。你——你读过——你读过国家——
I'm pretty smart. Pretty smart. And yeah, I've read the Constitution.
我很聪明。相当聪明。是的，我读过宪法。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交替的声音]
It's not as [INAUDIBLE] that. But you're not. You're not. What you're going to-- no, here's what you're going to do.
它不像那样。但你不是。你不是。你要做什么——不，你要做的是。
No, no, no, you're not going to tell me what I'm going to do. You're going to review-- you're going to review the national and state constitutions, is what's going to happen.
不，不，不，你不能告诉我我该做什么。你要审查——你要审查国家和州宪法，这就是要发生的事。
No, actually, it's not, Aubree--
不，其实不是，奥布里——
Are you-- are you now refusing to review the national and state constitutions for your own--
你是——你是现在拒绝审查国家和州宪法来为你的——
I am. And here's how I'm going to refuse that-- by the coming phone click that you're about to hear in 3, 2, 1.
我是。这就是我拒绝的方式——通过你即将在3、2、1听到电话点击声。
Because of these kinds of encounters between elections officials and activists, it gets very personal sometimes. In the last few years in Texas, lots of election administrators have quit or retired. The entire staff of an elections office in Gillespie County quit at the same time, because of accusations of fraud, obscene, racist emails, threats.
由于选举官员和活动人士之间发生此类冲突，有时会变得非常个人化。在过去几年的德克萨斯州，许多选举管理员辞职或退休。吉莱斯皮县选举办公室的全体工作人员同时辞职，原因就是欺诈指控、淫秽、种族主义邮件和威胁。
People call the cops on these officials and try to get them arrested while they're doing their jobs. But there is another path. That woman, Aubree Campbell, that you just heard-- she happens to live in a county in Texas-- Tarrant County, where the elections administrator is not the guy who you just heard on the phone.
人们打电话给警察举报这些官员，并在他们工作时试图逮捕他们。但还有另一条路。你刚才听到的那个女人，奥布里·坎贝尔——她恰好住在德克萨斯州的一个县——塔兰特县，那里的选举管理员不是你刚才在电话里听到的那个人。
The official in Tarrant County is this singular, kind of, remarkable figure. We learned about him from Natalia Contreras, who's been reporting on elections in Texas for months now, for Votebeat, which covers all this in depth around the country. Natalia says, there's really nobody else like him that she's been able to find.
塔兰特县的那位官员是一个独特且引人注目的形象。我们是从娜塔莉亚·孔特雷拉斯那里了解到的，她几个月来一直在为Votebeat报道德克萨斯州的选举，该网站深入报道了全国各地的情况。娜塔莉亚说，她找不到像他这样的人。
He's very effective, for some special reasons that Natalia will explain in a bit. His name is Heider Garcia. And watching him, it's hard not to feel like if anybody could convince the election doubters that our elections can be trusted-- or at the very least, if anybody can make headway with them, it would be this guy.
他非常有效率，原因特殊，娜塔莉亚稍后会解释。他的名字叫海德·加西亚。看着他，很难不让人觉得，如果有人能说服那些质疑者相信我们的选举是可以信任的——或者至少，如果有人能在他们身上取得进展，那会是这个人。
And to try to see how successful he is in winning over the election skeptics and the Stop the Stealers, and to see the limits of that success. Earlier this month, on election day, Natalia and Zoe Chace from our staff co-reported a story where the two of them followed Heider around as he managed the election in Tarrant County and as he dealt with the election doubters-- and Aubree, in particular. Here are Natalia and Zoe.
为了看看他在赢得选举怀疑论者和“停止窃选”派方面有多成功，并看看这种成功的局限性。本月早些时候，在选举日，娜塔莉亚和我们员工的佐伊·蔡斯合写了一篇报道，他们两人在海德管理塔兰特县选举并处理那些质疑者——特别是奥布里——时跟随他。这是娜塔莉亚和佐伊。
Let's start with Aubree. She's just one of many people in Texas who have made it almost their full-time job to challenge election officials.
让我们从奥布里开始。她是德克萨斯州许多人中的一个，这些人几乎把挑战选举官员当作全职工作。
And they all have some kind of story like this to explain how they got into it. In Tarrant County, when Joe Biden won, it didn't really make any sense to Aubree. It's a Republican county. Republicans won down the ballot. But the president-- somehow, Biden won.
他们都有一些这样的故事来解释他们是如何入行的。在塔兰特县，乔·拜登赢的时候，奥布里觉得这根本说不通。这是一个共和党县。共和党人在整个选票上都赢了。但总统——不知怎么的，拜登赢了。
Then, when Biden took Tarrant County, we were really upset, because Trump has a lot of vocal support here, and I don't know a single Democrat. And none of my Democrat friends voted for Biden in the primaries. They all voted for Bernie. So you talk to him one on one, they know something's not right.
当拜登拿下塔兰特县时，我们真的很沮丧，因为特朗普在这里有很多支持者，我不认识一个民主党人。我的民主党朋友在初选中都没有投票给拜登。他们都投给了桑德斯。所以你一对一地和他们谈，他们知道有些事情是不对劲的。
Aubree doesn't look like other activists I see in this world, who are mostly elderly and retired. She's 33, but looks way younger. She's white, petite, round, hipstery eyeglasses, leather jacket. She describes herself as a conservative metal head. She stands out.
奥布里看起来不像我在这个圈子里看到的其他大多是老年退休人员的活动人士。她33岁，看起来年轻得多。她是白人，娇小，圆脸，戴着时髦的眼镜，穿着皮夹克。她称自己为保守派金属乐迷。她很突出。
It was post-2020, because I remember the whole thing started with her interacting with an election judge.
那是2020年之后，因为我记得整件事开始于她与一位选举裁判官的互动。
This is Heider Garcia.
这是海德·加西亚。
She was really frustrated. She took out her cell phone, started recording the poll worker, saying, you're obstructing me from voting. The poll worker said, you can't use your phone here, and the whole situation started to happen. And that's when I started interacting with her, and, you know.
她真的很沮丧。她拿出手机，开始录像那个工作人员，说，你在阻碍我投票。工作人员说，你不能在这里使用手机，整个局面就开始发生了。这就是我开始和她互动的时候。
[RATTLING NOISE]
[咔嗒声]
Coffee?
咖啡吗？
It's 6:30 AM on election day. Heider Garcia is the kind of person who carries around his own coffee grinder to grind his own beans for his morning coffee. Fastidious? Neurotic? He has high standards for himself and his coffee.
选举日早上6:30。海德·加西亚就是那种随身携带咖啡研磨机自己磨咖啡豆的人。挑剔？神经质？他对自己的咖啡和自己都有很高的标准。
He oversees every aspect of the election with the same fastidiousness. He sets the whole thing up. He trains the workers. He tells us he's been working on not being a micromanager, which you only say if you are.
他以同样的挑剔监督选举的每一个方面。他一手操办全局。他培训工作人员。他告诉我们他一直努力不做一个微观管理者，这只有当你是的时候才会这么说。
Heider's taking a particular approach with people like Aubree. It's something I haven't seen any other Texas election officials do. His strategy is to go as far as humanly possible to answer every question and address every suspicion. He treats everything they say like it's worthy of an answer.
海德对像奥布里这样的人采取了一种特殊的方法。这是我没见过其他德克萨斯州选举官员做过的。他的策略是尽其所能回答每一个问题并解决每一个怀疑。他把他们说的每一件事都当作值得回答的事情来对待。
It's like radical patience. And when you see him do it, you see why other officials don't. Because it takes hours. It's a big part of his job now, on top of all the work of running an election.
这就像极度的耐心。当你看到他这样做时，你就明白为什么其他官员不这么做了。因为它需要花费数小时。现在这是他工作的一大重点，此外还有运行选举的所有工作。
They call with some issue. He's like, come in. Let me walk you through it. Let me show you around. Here's a typical example.
他们带着问题打电话来。他说，进来吧。让我带你了解一下。让我带你看看周围。这是一个典型的例子。
So there was this one time when one of our watchers came in, and he was like, you know, if I-- he was in a tally room with us, and he said-- this was back in-- I think it was last year. If I were in charge here, I would make all the walls in this room glass, so that you could see where every cable goes, and you could be totally transparent-- something like that.
有一次，一位观察员进来，他在我们的计票室里，他说——这是在——我想是去年。如果我负责这里，我会让这个房间的所有墙壁都变成玻璃，这样你就可以看到每根电缆的去向，你就可以完全透明——类似这样的。
And I looked at him and said, why do you want that? He says, well, because we should know where every wire goes, so we can know if you're connected to the internet or not. And I said, well, but the whole point is to show that the machines are not connected to the internet, right?
我看着他问，你为什么想要那样？他说，因为我们应该知道每根线的去向，这样我们才能知道你是否连接了互联网。我说，但重点是证明机器没有连接互联网，对吧？
We're talking about the servers and the tally room, so there shouldn't be any cable going in the machine. So I told him, what about if we rearrange the room, so the machines are not, like, in this little cabinet under the desk, but up where you can see them and you can-- he said, well, maybe that would be a start.
我们谈论的是服务器和计票室，所以机器里不应该有任何电缆进去。所以我告诉他，如果我们重新布置房间怎么样，机器不再放在桌下的那个小柜子里，而是放在你能看到的地方——他说，嗯，也许那会是一个开始。
So the next election, they came back in a runoff. You know, when they walked in the room, I told them, all the machines are on top of the tables. You can see the back. They're against the glass.
所以在下次决选时，他们又回来了。当他们走进房间时，我告诉他们，所有的机器都在桌子上。你可以看到背面。它们靠在玻璃上。
They're labeled what each one of them does. This is what you wanted, right? And so he had that moment of, again, OK, well, you got me on that one. And it's little things like that, that we keep doing, right?
它们被贴上了标签。这就是你想要的，对吧？所以他有那种“好的，好吧，在这点上你赢了”的时刻。我们一直在做像这样的小事。
In theory, any election official could go this far-- answer every question-- if they wanted to. Though, in some ways, Heider's uniquely suited for this, he's a computer engineer. He's designed voting machines.
理论上，任何选举官员都可以做到这一步——回答每一个问题——如果他们想的话。虽然从某些方面看，海德在这方面独具优势，他是计算机工程师。他设计过投票机。
So he can answer, in detail, any question, technical or not, in a way few officials ever can. And for this election morning, as people are going out to vote, he's rigged up his office like some kind of air traffic control tower. It's a big room, and he's installed this enormous screen in it, and we're looking at every polling place marked on a huge Google map-- 316 of them.
所以他可以详细回答任何问题，无论是技术性的还是其他的，这是很少有官员能做到的。在这个选举日的早晨，当人们出去投票时，他把办公室装扮得像一个空中交通管制塔。那是一个大房间，他在里面安装了一个巨大的屏幕，我们看着每个投票点在巨大的谷歌地图上被标记出来——316个。
They're all color-coded with wait times. If there's a problem at a polling place, the color changes to mark the level of urgency-- low, medium, critical. Then, on a separate map, Heider can see, if a tech is dispatched to fix something, he can watch them travel out there on the map, like an Uber. We can see how long it's going to take. Not long after the polls open, around 8 AM, he gets a call.
它们都用颜色编码表示等待时间。如果投票点有问题，颜色会变色以标记紧急程度——低、中、危急。然后在另一张地图上，海德可以看到，如果派遣技术人员去修理某样东西，他可以像优步一样在地图上看着他们赶过去。我们可以看到需要多长时间。投票站开放后不久，早上8点左右，他接到了一个电话。
[KNOCKING ON DOOR]
[敲门声]
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话响铃]
Heider holds up the phone to me. He points at it and says, it's Aubree. Hey. Morning. Doing good.
海德把手机举给我看。他指着它说，是奥布里。嘿。早上好。做得好。
So there's a picture going around, and it's purported to be a map of outages of all of the machines. Is that-- are you having issues with that? This is, like, a lot. I'm going to send it to you to-- just so you see what this is.
所以有一张照片在流传，据说是所有机器停机的地图。是这样吗——你们遇到问题了吗？这张太多了。我要发给你——让你看看这是什么。
All right.
好的。
People are-- it's going to go-- it's going to go crazy. It hasn't been shared publicly yet with the person who sent it-- from the person who sent it to me, but it could go-- you know how fast stuff can catch fire.
人们——这会变得——这会变得疯狂。发给我的人还没有公开分享它——但它可能会——你知道事情传播得有多快。
This is the kind of call she makes to election officials all over Texas. Like, something seems fishy here. And what do you have to say for yourself before it goes viral?
这就是她给德克萨斯州各地的选举官员打的那种电话。就像，这里看起来有些不对劲。在你发出去疯传之前，你有什么要辩解的吗？
Yeah, send it to me. I'll take a look, see what it is. Please, that'd be great.
好的，发给我。我会看一下，看看是什么。请吧，那太好了。
Yeah, I texted it to you. And so this is what it looks like. And so I don't know what this is, but if that's what that is--
是的，我发短信给你了。这就是它看起来的样子。所以我不知道这是什么，但如果那是那样——
That's the wait time. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. That is the map of wait times.
那是等待时间。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。那是等待时间地图。
It's literally the map we're looking at that's also on the elections website, with the wait times of polling places. It's not a map of outages.
这实际上就是我们在选举网站上也看到的地图，上面有投票点的等待时间。这不是停机地图。
That's every single polling place in Tarrant County, and it's showing the wait times. They should be in green, yellow, and red, for short, medium, and long lines. And actually, if you look at the picture, it says right there.
那是塔兰特县的每一个投票点，显示的是等待时间。它们应该是绿色、黄色和红色的，表示短、中、长队伍。实际上，如果你看那张照片，它就在上面写着。
Yeah. But I didn't know if that's exact. I didn't know-- I don't know the--
是的。但我不知道它是否准确。我不知道——我不知道——
All right. No, that's fine. Send me anything you have a concern about. We'll look into it.
好的。没关系。把你关心的任何事情发给我。我们会调查的。
OK, I'll make sure that they understand that, they don't share it out wrong.
好的，我会确保他们理解这一点，不会分享错误。
Awesome. Appreciate it.
太棒了。谢谢。
All right. Bye.
好的。再见。
Bye.
再见。
Shockingly amicable. It doesn't escalate. And she seems to believe him, which is wild to me, to see one of these election fraud activists actually take the word of an elections official. She seems to trust what he's saying, because of all her dealings with Heider to this point. Heider says she calls a lot.
令人震惊的友好。事情没有升级。她似乎相信他，这对我来说很疯狂，看到这些选举欺诈活动人士之一竟然听取了选举官员的话。她似乎信任他所说的话，因为她到目前为止与海德的所有接触。海德说她打了很多次电话。
To the point where you have her number saved, and every-- She has your number.
到你保存了她的号码，每——她有你的号码。
Yeah, yeah, no, and I give everybody-- everybody-- I give everyone my cell phone. I'd rather they call me directly and say, hey, you know, do this. Deal with it, rather than wait until it snowballs.
是的，是的，不，我给每个人——每个人——我给每个人我的手机号。我宁愿他们直接打电话给我说，嘿，你知道，做这个。处理它，而不是等到它滚雪球般扩大。
And I find out at 4:00 in the afternoon that the map has been going around, it's like, done. I told you what it is. Doesn't go any further than that, hopefully.
下午4点我发现地图在流传，就像，完了。我已经告诉你那是什么了。希望不会再有进一步的发展。
Heider's clicking around on his computer. He's watching the polling places. He has calls coming in. He's checking in with his wife and kids. He's got the news on. He says he's glad he's not in Arizona.
海德在电脑上点击着。他看着投票站。他有电话打进来。他和妻子孩子联系。他开着新闻。他说他很高兴自己不在亚利桑那州。
He's also on Twitter and on Telegram. He spends a lot of time, election day and always, monitoring what the activists are saying to anticipate what they're going to want from him.
他也在推特和Telegram上。他花了很多时间，在选举日和任何时候，监控活动人士在说什么，以预测他们想要他做什么。
Heider is so fanatical about following these channels, that when he hears about a new conspiracy theory, he'll dive deep and work it all the way out, so he can disprove it if anyone brings it up. Like, this one guy Aubree was talking about-- this kind of famous right-wing activist, Seth Keshel, who goes by Captain K. He had some math that supposedly proved that Trump won Tarrant County.
海德对于跟踪这些渠道非常痴迷，当他听到一个新的阴谋论时，他会深入研究并彻底查清，这样如果有人提起，他就可以反驳它。就像奥布里谈到的那个人——这个有点著名的右翼活动人士，塞思·凯舍尔（Seth Keshel），大家都叫他凯队长（Captain K）。他有一些数学计算声称证明特朗普赢得了塔兰特县。
OK. I actually looked at his methodology and tried to run the numbers. And just to understand, because people come in here-- I got some of these people who come in and say, "well, Captain Keshel said--" well, first of all, it's so flawed, the whole method, right?
好的。我确实看了他的方法论，并试着算了一下数字。只是为了理解，因为人们来到这里——我有一些人来这里说，“嗯，凯舍尔队长说——”好吧，首先，整个方法太有缺陷了，对吧？
So I've explained it to them. I said, have you actually run the numbers on his method and do you understand how it works? No. So I sat her down and I explained to her the math behind it. Said, you understand that this is bullshit, right?
所以我向他们解释了。我说，你真的用他的方法算过数字吗，你理解它是怎么运作的吗？没有。所以我让她坐下来，向她解释了背后的数学。说，你明白这是胡扯，对吧？
What's the premise that he's using that's the false premise?
他使用的那个错误前提是什么？
That he can project how people vote in November based on how the primary was. Let's geek out.
他可以根据初选情况来预测人们在11月如何投票。让我们钻研一下技术细节。
[LAUGHS] Let's geek out!
[笑] 让我们钻研一下！
Heider just happens to have a whiteboard and markers handy. He starts drawing a line graph to show us.
海德刚好手头有一块白板和记号笔。他开始画折线图给我们看。
Here's what he says. He says that he can take the registration from any point in time.
这是他说的。他说他可以从任何时间点获取登记数据。
He walks us through it, just like he did for Aubree. The Captain really drives him crazy. Just today he saw him railing against early voting on his telegram channel.
他带着我们过了一遍，就像他为奥布里做的那样。队长真的很让他抓狂。就在今天，他看到他在Telegram频道上抨击提前投票。
His voting history, have you looked at it? I just looked today.
他的投票记录，你看过吗？我今天刚看了。
You just look today at Seth Keshel's voting history?
你今天看了塞思·凯舍尔的投票记录？
He says, we have to get rid of early voting. Early voting is not safe. For the last 10 years, he's voted early voting every single election.
他说，我们必须取消提前投票。提前投票不安全。过去10年，他每次选举都提前投票。
We checked-- it's at least the past six years.
我们查了——至少过去六年是这样。
As you go through his voting history and you compare what he says to what he does, it's like, dude, really? You want to get rid of all these things because it's not safe, but you take advantage of them because you need to and because it's more convenient for you?
当你审视他的投票记录并对比他的言行时，就像，老兄，真的吗？你想废除所有这些东西，因为它们不安全，但你却利用它们，因为你需要，而且因为它对你来说更方便？
You, Heider, are taking the time to make a public records request. What are you even going to do with that?
海德，你正在花时间做公开记录请求。你打算用它做什么？
Nothing. Some of these people, again, it's kind of like should I take this one serious or not?
什么都不做。有些人，同样，就像我该认真对待这一条还是不该？
Heider started monitoring the stuff at first, because he was worried about his own safety. Back in 2020, he was at the center of a national trolling firestorm. Because even though he was born in the United States, he grew up in Venezuela and worked for a while for the voting machine company Smartmatic. You know Smartmatic-- it's at the center of a ton of conspiracy theories. Heider's name blew up.
海德起初开始监控这些东西，是因为他担心自己的安全。早在2020年，他就处于全国性网络喷子风暴的中心。因为虽然他出生在美国，但他是在委内瑞拉长大的，并在投票机公司Smartmatic工作过一段时间。你知道Smartmatic——它处于大量阴谋论的中心。海德的名字炸开了锅。
Heider Garcia-- this Venezuelan-born operative now serves, believe it or not, as election administrator for Tarrant County, Texas. That's a county which turned blue for the first time since 1964, after the introduction of-- dum, dum, dum-- new electronic voting machines. Hm. While evading--
海德·加西亚——这个出生于委内瑞拉的特工，信不信由你，现在担任德克萨斯州塔兰特县的选举管理员。那是一个自1964年以来首次变蓝的县，在引入了——咚，咚，咚——新型电子投票机之后。嗯。同时躲避——
That's Michelle Malkin on Newsmax. Trump allies Sidney Powell and Lou Dobbs were also talking about him. After that, he got lots of racist messages. He got death threats. People shared his home address online.
那是米歇尔·马尔金在Newsmax上的节目。特朗普的盟友西德尼·鲍威尔和卢·多布斯也在谈论他。在那之后，他收到了很多种族主义信息。他收到了死亡威胁。人们在网上分享了他的家庭住址。
And suddenly local activists in Texas had this hometown supervillain to investigate, and talk about, and publicize. People made their own videos. Aubree made one that's two hours long. It's called Heider Smartmatic Garcia, and it included a lot of inaccurate information about his time with Smartmatic.
突然之间，德克萨斯州的当地活动人士有了一个要调查、谈论和曝光的家乡超级反派。人们制作了自己的视频。奥布里制作了一个长达两小时的视频。它叫《海德·Smartmatic·加西亚》，里面包含了很多关于他在Smartmatic工作期间的不准确信息。
He sold their machines to the legislature of the Philippines. So not only did he design the machines, I mean, this guy is a real go-getter. He also went out and sold it to the Philippines, who later had a big, big issue with them. We'll flip over and watch that video in just a moment. He was also--
他把机器卖给了菲律宾立法机构。所以他不仅设计了机器，我的意思是，这家伙是个实干家。他还跑去卖给了菲律宾，后者后来在机器上遇到了大麻烦。我们稍后会切过去看那个视频。他还——
At some point, Heider decided he had nothing to hide. He didn't do anything wrong. He went on the offensive, submitted testimony to Congress, threatened to sue Aubree for defamation. She put out an apology video.
在某个时刻，海德决定他没有什么可隐瞒的。他没做错任何事。他转入攻势，向国会提交证词，威胁要起诉奥布里诽谤。她发布了一个道歉视频。
OK, I have to issue what I guess you could call a retraction.
好的，我必须发布一个我想你可以称之为撤回声明的声明。
I just want to be clear. Aubree is not some big, famous internet activist. She has fewer than 1,000 followers. She works in restaurants. She's part of this whole world of people out there on Telegram and stuff like that, since the election sharing their own analysis of what they think is election fraud-- probably sincerely, and asking for donations. What makes Heider so mad about Aubree and some others is he sees it like she's using this narrative of him that she's fighting this big, bad Venezuelan operative to build up her own brand.
我只想澄清一点。奥布里不是什么著名的网络活动人士。她不到1000个粉丝。她在餐馆工作。她是自选举以来Telegram等圈子里那些分享自己对选举欺诈分析的人的一部分——可能是真诚的，并请求捐款。海德对奥布里和其他人感到愤怒的原因是，他认为她利用关于他的叙事，声称她在与这个邪恶的委内瑞拉特工斗争，来建立自己的品牌。
Does she sell merchandise?
她卖周边产品吗？
Yep.
是的。
What does she sell?
她卖什么？
That stuff there. I bought two shirts and two mugs.
那些东西。我买了两个衬衫和两个杯子。
No, you didn't.
不，你没有。
He didn't. Aubree says she doesn't sell much merch, and she doesn't ask for donations much either. The merch reads "Taking Back Texas," which is Aubree's brand.
他没有。奥布里说她卖的不多，也不会要求太多捐款。周边商品上印着“收回德州”（Taking Back Texas），这是奥布里的品牌。
Oh, that is a lot of merch.
哦，那可是很多周边。
Throughout the morning, Heider's constantly running back and forth, checking in on the people managing the phone bank, to the point where one of them literally says to him, Heider, I need to focus now. His phone keeps blowing up with calls about minor technical issues, machines going down at polling places.
整个上午，海德不断跑来跑去，查看管理电话银行的人，以至于他们中的一个真的对他说了，海德，我现在需要专注。他的手机不断响着关于微小技术问题的电话，投票站的机器出了故障。
Arlington, Miller-- that's the hot spot right now. I've got calls from both sides on that one.
阿灵顿，米勒——那是现在的热点。那件事我两边都接到了电话。
There's other types of problems-- people problems. One poll worker, while demonstrating how to help voters vote, accidentally voted as someone else with a similar name. There's a problem with the poll judge-- well, with the alternate to the judge.
还有其他类型的问题——人员问题。一名投票站工作人员在演示如何帮助选民投票时，不小心以一个同名的人的身份投了票。选举裁判官有问题——好吧，是裁判官的替补。
Question-- I do have one for you. Judge called and said she thinks her alternate has been drinking and is carrying-- [LAUGHS] --and carrying, and carrying. And apparently he said something like, I'm carrying, and I'm here to protect you if necessary. And she said she smelled alcohol. So we're going to tell him to call law enforcement and have them assess the situation.
问题——我确实有一个要问你。裁判官打电话说她认为她的替补喝了酒，并且带着——[笑] ——带着，带着。显然他说了一些类似的话，我带着武器，如果有必要我会保护你们。她说她闻到了酒精味。所以我们要让他打给执法部门，让他们评估情况。
Mostly Heider's upbeat, excited, jokey. When his assistant Troy brags about how he's about to buy an F-150 hybrid, Heider's like, can you not drive it to work right after the election? People are going to be like, see, they got that big George Soros payout-- your "Ford Soros," he says.
海德大多很乐观、兴奋、爱开玩笑。当他的助手特洛伊吹嘘说他要买一辆福特F-150混动车时，海德说，你能在选举后别把它开到工作单位吗？人们会说，看，他们拿到了乔治·索罗斯那笔大钱——你的“福特索罗斯”，他说。
Heider's phone rings. It's Aubree again.
海德的电话响了。又是奥布里。
Hey.
嘿。
Hey, sorry. So someone kind of prominent locally is saying that she's been told machines in Hurst are down and that they're not going to be serviced or replaced.
嘿，抱歉。所以当地有个相当知名的人说，她被告知赫斯特的机器坏了，而且不会被维修或更换。
In a mostly Republican part of town, a controller went out. The line was long. This is the kind of thing that happens in every election. Usually it's no big deal, but now everyone is suspicious they're being targeted.
在城里一个主要是共和党人的地方，控制器坏了。排队很长。这是每次选举中都会发生的这类事情。通常这不是什么大事，但现在每个人都怀疑他们是被针对了。
No, Brookside did have an issue. There was a tech dispatched there a while ago. They should be on-site, actually, right now. Yeah, nothing's not going to not get serviced. That'd be the stupidest mistake I can make. [LAUGHS]
不，布鲁克赛德确实出了问题。不久前有技术人员被派往那里。实际上，他们现在应该在现场了。是的，没有什么是不会被维修的。那是我能犯下的最愚蠢的错误。[笑]
All right, so do you have a lot of other locations where the controllers or the tabulator went down?
好的，那你有其他控制器或计票器坏了的位置吗？
I think a grapevine in the library-- they had two strings and one of them had an issue-- and Miller. I think that one was a scanner. But that's not a problem, because they can still vote. They just put them in the emergency bin on the board. Ballot board adds them in once we get it back here.
我想图书馆里有个葡萄园——他们有两串，其中一个出了问题——还有米勒。我想那个是扫描仪。但这没问题，因为他们仍然可以投票。他们只是把它们放进董事会的紧急箱里。计票委员会一旦把它们拿回来就会加入进去。
Oh, yeah, they're going to throw a fit about that though.
哦，是的，不过他们会为此大发雷霆的。
This happened on a huge scale in Arizona, and people did throw a fit about it. Aubree tells Heider she's going to go check it out for herself.
这种情况在亚利桑那州大规模发生，人们确实大发雷霆。奥布里告诉海德她要亲自去看看。
I don't care if you call me 100 times a day, because I'd rather hear as soon as I can and get on it.
我不介意你一天打100次电话，因为我宁愿尽早听到并解决它。
It's almost like he's deputized her. Sometimes they seem like colleagues. I can't tell whose strategy that is, or whether it's working, but it seems to calm things. In the end, the broken scanner wasn't a big deal.
简直就像他把她任命为副手一样。有时他们看起来像同事。我不知道那是谁的策略，或者是否有效，但这似乎让事情平静了下来。最后，扫描仪坏掉并不是什么大事。
Finally, when we get near 7:00 when polls will close, poll watchers start piling in from voting sites around the county. Not as many as we had expected. When Aubree walks in, her first question is about Heider.
最后，当接近7:00投票站即将关闭时，观察员开始从全县的投票点涌入。没有我们预期的那么多。当奥布里走进来时，她的第一个问题是关于海德的。
"Do you know where he is?" she says to someone. "He probably doesn't want me walking around here too much on my own." Again, Heider and Aubree interact like colleagues almost-- colleagues who don't really like each other, frenemies?
“你知道他在哪吗？”她对某人说。“他可能不想让我自己在这里走来走去。”又是这样，海德和奥布里之间的互动几乎就像同事——不太喜欢对方的同事，冤家？
Hello?
喂？
Hey, how are you?
嘿，你好吗？
I'm doing good. How's it going?
我很好。进展如何？
Good.
很好。
Notice how they're talking past each other-- but so politely.
注意他们是如何客气地自说自话的。
The lines were kind of long, but--
队伍有点长，但是——
But they're moving quick, aren't they?
但移动得很快，不是吗？
Well, the ones I went to, what's it called, Euless Family Center?
嗯，我去的那些，叫什么，尤利斯家庭中心？
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
Oh, my gosh.
天哪。
That's a great place. It's really big, open.
那是个好地方。它很大，开放。
It is.
是的。
Is that the one? Yeah.
是那个吗？是的。
But, man, they had so many people.
但是，天哪，人太多了。
Yeah.
是的。
And they said they could have used an extra poll book or two.
他们说他们本来可以用额外的投票登记册。
OK. This way. Well, you know the way.
好的。这边。好吧，你知道路。
I know.
我知道。
Finally, it's time to count the votes. There's one hilarious looking ritual first.
终于到了计票的时候了。首先有一个看起来很搞笑的仪式。
Oh, here we go!
哦，开始了！
Oh.
哦。
The walk of shame.
羞耻之行。
The absentee ballots are on a USB drive. And to move that USB drive into the tally room where they'll be added to the results, the drive is lifted high into the air for all watchers to see and marched like a winning quarterback into the next room. It's symbolic of Heider's whole approach to things-- flamboyantly transparent.
缺席选票在USB驱动器上。为了把那个驱动器带进计票室加入结果，驱动器被高高举起给所有观察员看，像获胜的四分卫一样行进到下一个房间。这象征着海德处理事情的整个方式——华丽地透明。
No, that's why we have the GoPro.
不，这就是我们有GoPro的原因。
Someone holds a GoPro up high so the entire march of the USB drive is recorded in case anyone asks later, what happened between the two rooms?
有人把GoPro高高举起，这样USB驱动器的整个行进过程都被记录下来，以防有人后来问，两个房间之间发生了什么？
We should do like a chair, like a throne chair, and we should carry it on the shoulders, all of us in the procession, but with just a USB drive sitting on the chair.
我们应该弄把椅子，像宝座一样，我们应该把它扛在肩上，我们所有人都在队列中，但上面只放一个USB驱动器。
We get to the back room where they're counting votes. This is where the hardcore election skeptics are camped out for the night.
我们到了他们计票的后室。这里是那些死硬的选举怀疑论者彻夜驻扎的地方。
There's Amy. She's in a red, white, and blue dress with a clipboard, scrutinizing the way the ballot bags are sealed. Mike, he's a retired air mechanic who says, if we can audit planes, why can't we do better with elections here? He's there. Karen, she has a lawsuit against Heider.
那是艾米。她穿着一件红白蓝相间的裙子，拿着一块写字板，仔细检查选票袋的密封方式。迈克，他是一位退休的飞机机械师，他说，如果我们能审计飞机，为什么选举不能做得更好？他在那儿。凯伦，她对海德有诉讼。
There's maybe a dozen people he deals with regularly, like Aubree. He knows all of these people well, and he's trying to anticipate what they'll want. And does it work? Are they satisfied?
可能有十几个人是他经常处理的，比如奥布里。他非常了解这些人，他试图预测他们想要什么。这有效吗？他们满意吗？
I will say this, Heider makes other election administrators look like idiots.
我会说这个，海德让其他选举管理员看起来像白痴。
Again, here's Aubree.
再说一次，这是奥布里。
Well, he'll answer all your questions, so we're getting places. He's made some changes that I like.
嗯，他会回答你所有的问题，所以我们正在取得进展。他做了一些我喜欢的改变。
Like what?
比如什么？
He's adding all of the result tapes for election day onto the website. He's doing a lot of stuff that's helping, and that's more than other election administrators.
他把选举日的所有结果胶带都加到了网站上。他做了很多有帮助的事情，这比其他选举管理员要多。
Do you think that's helped in any way your confidence in the system, if you will?
你认为这对你对系统的信心有帮助吗？
No, not in the system. I do not trust the system. But it's helped me understand the system more.
不，不是对系统的信心。我不信任这个系统。但这帮助我更多地了解了系统。
Trust it? No. I don't trust computerized voting systems. Computers can be hacked-- they always can. Whether that's happening right now, we're unable to fully investigate.
信任它？不。我不信任计算机化的投票系统。电脑可能会被黑客攻击——它们总是可以的。无论现在是否正在发生，我们无法完全调查。
Even after everything Heider's done to convince her otherwise, she doesn't believe the process is secure enough in Tarrant County to say for sure that the votes were accurately counted. This past year I've wondered, can you convince someone that an election is not stolen?
即使在海德做了所有这一切来说服她之后，她仍然不相信塔兰特县的过程足够安全，以至于不能确定选票是被准确计算的。过去一年我一直在想，你能说服某人选举没有被偷走吗？
And what I realized watching Heider is, that is not the right question to ask right now. That's an endpoint we're not going to arrive at. The activists aren't going away. Instead, what Heider is trying, he's integrating the election skeptics and all their questions into the elections office and the way it works.
我看着海德意识到，现在问这个问题是不对的。那是我们无法到达的终点。活动人士不会离开。相反，海德正在尝试的，是将选举怀疑论者及其所有问题整合到选举办公室及其运作方式中。
It's the job. Maybe there's no point. Maybe that's just the job. You know, maybe there's no endgame. Maybe that's just the way it is.
这就是工作。也许没意义。也许这就是工作。你知道，也许没有终局。也许事情就是这样。
Like I said, if there is a shooting, police jumps into it. If there was a fire, a firefighter. [INAUDIBLE] questions, that's ours. Not because it's going to end, because it's your job. It's your job, it's simple.
就像我说的，如果发生枪击，警察就会介入。如果发生火灾，消防员就会介入。[听不清] 问题，那是我们的。不是因为它会结束，因为这是你的工作。这是你的工作，很简单。
And in this new normal on this election night, the job's gone as well as he could hope. The activists still have their doubts, a few of them already setting up meetings with Heider for later that week. There's a new conspiracy every day.
在这个选举之夜的新常态下，工作进行得和他希望的一样顺利。活动人士仍然有疑问，其中几个人已经安排好那周晚些时候和海德见面。每天都有一个新的阴谋。
But no one yells. No one throws a fit saying they're being obstructed. And Heider rushes around to everyone, like the anxious owner of a restaurant, checking on their regulars, making sure they have everything they need. And the votes get counted.
但没有人尖叫。没有人因为说他们被阻碍而大发雷霆。海德像个焦虑的餐馆老板一样围着每个人跑，查看他们的常客，确保他们拥有所需的一切。选票也被计算了。
Natalia Contreras is a reporter with Votebeat. You can find her work at Votebeat.org. Zoe Chace is a producer on our show.
娜塔莉亚·孔特雷拉斯是Votebeat的记者。你可以在Votebeat.org找到她的作品。佐伊·蔡斯是我们节目的制作人。
Coming up, we watch a guy during the exact moment he is crossing through the looking glass to the other side. And we can see it, because he's on national TV on a game show. That's in a minute on Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，我们将看到一个人在穿过镜子走到另一边的那一刻。我们可以看到，因为他在电视节目上。那是芝加哥公共广播电台一分钟后的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, Through the Looking Glass. People trying to coax each other across the border from one way of seeing the world to another way.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在我们的节目中，透过镜子。人们试图诱导对方跨越界限，从一种看待世界的方式到另一种方式。
We have arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, Who is Ryan Long?
我们已经到了我们节目的第二幕。第二幕，谁是瑞安·朗？
So in this story you're going to see a guy trying to actually coax himself through the looking glass from one reality into another. Lots of people actually saw him do this. One of our producers, Bim Adewunmi, was one of them.
在这个故事中，你会看到一个人试图诱导自己穿过镜子，从一个现实进入另一个现实。很多人亲眼目睹他这样做。我们的制作人之一，比姆·阿德温米，就是其中之一。
Back in May, I became mildly obsessed with a stranger on TV. It was a big guy. He looked Black, biracial maybe, and he was wearing a light purple shirt under a black vest.
回到五月，我开始有点痴迷于电视上的一个陌生人。那是个大块头。他看起来是黑人，也许是混血儿，他穿了一件浅紫色衬衫，外面穿了一件黑色背心。
I was ill on my sofa. It was 7:00 PM on a Friday. You know what that means.
我当时生病躺在沙发上。那是周五晚上7:00。你知道那意味着什么。
This is Jeopardy! Introducing today's contestants, a rideshare driver from Philadelphia, Pennsylvania, Ryan Long.
这是《危险边缘》（Jeopardy!）。介绍今天的选手，来自宾夕法尼亚州费城的拼车司机，瑞安·朗。
A rideshare driver. I watch a lot of Jeopardy, but if you don't, you might not know that it is not that common among all the professors and the grad students and other learned contestants to see an Uber driver. Also unusual in my years of watching-- big Black guys.
拼车司机。我看很多《危险边缘》，但如果你不看，你可能不知道在所有教授、研究生和其他博学的选手中间，看到一个优步司机并不常见。在我看节目的这些年里，这也是不寻常的——高大的黑人。
Ryan won that first game, and then he kept on winning. In the end, he won almost $300,000 over 16 games, becoming the ninth winningest Jeopardy winner of all time. After pretty much every win, he would do this thing that I began to look forward to. He'd grip the lectern, look down, almost defiantly refusing to meet the host's eye, and shake his head. His body language basically screamed "this can't be real, this is impossible."
瑞安赢得了第一场比赛，然后他一直赢。最终，他在16场比赛中赢得了近30万美元，成为《危险边缘》历史上第九大赢家。几乎每次获胜后，他都会做一个我开始期待的动作。他会抓住讲台，低头看，几乎是挑衅地拒绝直视主持人的眼睛，然后摇头。他的肢体语言基本上尖叫着“这不可能是真的，这不可能”。
Ryan, congratulations! With $18,800, you are our new Jeopardy champion.
瑞安，祝贺你！以18,800美元，你是我们新的《危险边缘》冠军。
I took a photo of Ryan on my TV screen that first night he won, and posted it to Instagram. "You have my sword," I captioned the photo, a line from "The Lord of the Rings."
在那晚他获胜后，我给电视屏幕上的瑞安拍了张照片，并发布到Instagram上。“你拥有我的剑，”我为这张照片配文，这是《指环王》中的一句台词。
Here's a thing about me-- I love trivia. I was a childhood library lurker who hoarded facts, just waiting to bust them out and impress people. I love remembering dates and locations, and I delight in wordplay.
关于我有一件事——我热爱冷知识。我是一个儿时的图书馆徘徊者，囤积事实，只等着把它们爆出来给人留下深刻印象。我喜欢记住日期和地点，我喜欢文字游戏。
Watching Ryan win again and again reminded me of myself a little, except he was me to the power of 100. It sounds condescending and weird, because we're about the same age, in our very late 30s, but I was proud of him, I think.
看着瑞安一次又一次获胜，让我想起了一点点我自己，除了他是我的100倍。这听起来有点居高临下和奇怪，因为我们年纪相仿，在30多岁末尾，但我为他感到骄傲，我想。
I rarely feel affection for Jeopardy winners. They're too mannered, too serious, too odd. But I was rooting for Ryan. I felt like I knew him.
我很少对《危险边缘》的赢家感到亲切。他们太讲究、太严肃、太古怪。但我支持瑞安。我觉得我认识他。
He had tweeted after his winning run something that stuck with me, something about a box. "Sometimes," he wrote, "it seems like society put you in a box and you are classified as a certain thing, with a certain destiny, even though you may feel differently inside."
他在获胜后发的一条推文引起了我的共鸣，关于一个盒子的事情。“有时，”他写道，“社会似乎把你放在一个盒子里，你被归类为某种东西，有着某种命运，尽管你在内心深处可能有不同的感觉。”
I wondered how somebody who felt so familiar to me had ended up dominating the Jeopardy stage. What was that like for him? What box did he think he was in, and how had Jeopardy helped him break out of it?
我想知道一个对我感觉如此熟悉的人是怎么最终统治了《危险边缘》舞台的。对他来说那是什么感觉？他认为自己在什么盒子里，以及《危险边缘》是如何帮助他打破它的？
Honestly, I just wanted to meet him. And so, along with my colleague and co-Ryan fan, Zoe Chace, I got on a train to Philadelphia. He met us in his new truck at the station.
老实说，我只是想见他。于是，我和我的同事，瑞安的忠实粉丝，佐伊·蔡斯，坐火车去了费城。他在车站接到了我们，开着他的新卡车。
Hi, Ryan.
嘿，瑞安。
Which, by the way, we knew immediately that was Ryan's car. It still has that new car gleam, and it is huge-- exactly the car you would expect from a man whose happy place is his car. Even before he became a rideshare driver, he would spend hours driving around navigating the potholes of Philly with his music on. So Zoe and I ended up spending all day on the road with him and meeting a couple of his friends. And the first question from Ryan felt like something you might ask a friend.
顺便说一句，我们立刻就知道那是瑞安的车。它仍然有那种新车的光泽，而且它很大——正是你从一个以车为乐的人那里所期望的车。甚至在他成为拼车司机之前，他就会花几个小时开车在费城的坑洼中导航，播放着音乐。所以佐伊和我最后整天和他在一起，并见了他的几个朋友。瑞安的第一个问题听起来像是你可以问朋友的问题。
All right, let's start off with a weird question. Do either one of you have any lotion?
好了，让我们从一个奇怪的问题开始。你们俩有人带乳液吗？
Lotion?
乳液？
I have hand cream, is that going to do it?
我有护手霜，那个可以吗？
That'll do.
那个就行。
OK.
好的。
I just have face moisturizer.
我只有面部保湿霜。
Yeah, my arms are so dry.
是的，我的胳膊太干了。
Oh, bless you.
哦，保佑你。
And about 20 minutes after we'd met, an aside about Michael Jackson's autobiography somehow led us here.
大约在我们见面20分钟后，关于迈克尔·杰克逊自传的一个侧面评论不知何故把我们带到了这里。
Who's your favorite Bond?
你最喜欢的邦德是谁？
Connery, what?
康纳利，什么？
Wow.
哇。
What?
什么？
That's amazing. I feel like Connery is up there, but you know who my favorite is, seriously?
那太棒了。我觉得康纳利很棒，但你知道我最喜欢的是谁吗，说真的？
Don't say Daniel Craig.
别说是丹尼尔·克雷格。
No.
不。
Oh. Timothy Dalton?
哦。蒂莫西·道尔顿？
Timothy Dalton!
蒂莫西·道尔顿！
He never got the respect he deserved.
他从来没有得到他应得的尊重。
He never got--
他从来没有得到——
Never!
从来没有！
--the respect he deserved!
——他应得的尊重！
No.
不。
OK, good.
好的，好极了。
I'll tell you this for free-- There is no loneliness like the loneliness of those of us in the "Timothy Dalton is the best James Bond" camp.
我免费告诉你这个——没有一种孤独像我们这些“蒂莫西·道尔顿是最好的詹姆斯·邦德”阵营里的那种孤独。
I'm telling you.
我告诉你。
Oh, my god. I love Timothy Dalton so much.
噢，天哪。我太爱蒂莫西·道尔顿了。
I watched "The Living Daylights" so many times. And the way he always hit the words.
我看过《黎明杀机》那么多次。他说话的方式。
Yes!
是的！
Yes! Talking to the-- what's the Russian guy? Georgi--
是的！跟那个——那个俄罗斯人叫什么？乔治——
Yeah.
是的。
--Koskov.
——科斯科夫。
Koskov!
科斯科夫！
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
And when he's talking, he goes, "Felix Leiter," you could tell he was a stage actor.
当他说话时，他说，“费利克斯·雷特”，你可以看出他是位舞台演员。
The road to the Alex Trebek stage at Sony Pictures Studios started early for Ryan. Like me, he was a voracious reader who liked to read the dictionary for fun. Unlike me, Ryan was reading the newspaper by the age of two.
通往索尼影业摄影棚的亚历克斯·特雷贝克舞台的道路对于瑞安来说开始得很早。和我一样，他是个贪婪的读者，喜欢为了娱乐阅读字典。不像我，瑞安两岁时就在看报纸了。
And his mom Angela told me he used to carry the cards from the trivial pursuit game she'd bought. One of his favorite childhood books was "Anguished English," an anthology of grammar humor. And, yes, Ryan loved Jeopardy.
他妈妈安吉拉告诉我，他过去经常带着她买的冷知识追求游戏的卡片。他最喜欢的童书之一是《苦涩的英语》，这是一本语法幽默选集。是的，瑞安热爱《危险边缘》。
I would have loved to have met Alex Trebek. He was a hero in my house. He's one of few white men I know that can pull off a perm.
我本来很想见见亚历克斯·特雷贝克。他是我家的英雄。他是少数几个我认识的能驾驭烫发的白人之一。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
Ryan, who's a big man now, describes himself as "husky" when he was a kid, which made him feel awkward and self-conscious. Plus, he was also in the midst of working out his mixed identity back then. His mom is Black and his father was white. And on top of that, he was an obviously smart kid. So they put him in the gifted classes, which also made him feel a little isolated.
现在已经长大成人的瑞安描述自己小时候是“强壮的”，这让他感到尴尬和自我意识过剩。此外，他那时正处于理清自己混血身份的过程中。他妈妈是黑人，父亲是白人。最重要的是，他是个显然很聪明的孩子。所以他们把他放在天才班，这也让他感到有点孤立。
I was smart and stupid at the same time. I had no idea how to relate to people. I lived in my head.
我既聪明又愚蠢。我不知道如何与人相处。我活在自己的脑子里。
Uh-huh, which is good for accumulation of stuff, but--
嗯，这有利于积累东西，但——
Yeah.
是的。
--perhaps less useful--
——也许用处较小——
But not great for relating to other people.
但不擅长与人相处。
Uh-huh.
嗯。
I used to downplay my intelligence like a motherfucker.
我过去经常像个混蛋一样贬低自己的智慧。
Really?
真的吗？
Like crazy. I would just stay quiet. Because I would have an opinion on a topic or something like that, and I was afraid that it would go over the other kids' heads and they would look at me like I got three eyes or something. So I would just keep my mouth shut. You feel like you got to fit in.
疯狂地。我只会保持安静。因为我对某个话题有看法或其他什么，我害怕它会超出其他孩子的理解能力，他们会看着我，就像我长了三只眼睛什么的。所以我会闭嘴。你觉得你必须合群。
This was his first understanding that people have ideas about you, and those ideas might not match how you feel about yourself. It was also the first time Ryan felt put into that box that he tweeted about. And in order to fit, he had to cut parts of himself off.
这是他第一次理解人们对他有看法，而那些看法可能与他对自己的感觉不符。这也是瑞安第一次感到被放进他发推特提到的那个盒子里。为了合群，他不得不切掉自己的一部分。
In the end, Ryan didn't do great at school. His parents had split up when he was 13, and he'd gone to live with his dad. A few years later, when he was 17, his father died and Ryan moved back in with his mom.
最终，瑞安在学校表现不佳。他父母在他13岁时离异，他随父亲生活。几年后，在他17岁时，父亲去世了，瑞安搬回去和妈妈住。
According to Ryan, he barely graduated high school, and then did a year of community college before dropping out. It's like he got so used to hiding away the brightest parts of himself, that he got really good at it-- too good. The way Ryan tells it, he settled into the role of underachiever, and that made him prone to self-sabotage.
据瑞安说，他勉强高中毕业，然后在退学前读了一年社区学院。就像他习惯了隐藏自己最亮眼的部分，以至于变得非常擅长——太擅长了。按瑞安的说法，他陷入了落后者的角色，这让他容易自我毁灭。
It'll be something like a subconscious thing where I know I got an important meeting or something, I got to be somewhere. And my brain, I'll have this urge to just, "you know what, just roll over."
这就像一种潜意识的东西，我知道我有一个重要的会议什么的，我必须去某个地方。我的大脑，我会有这种冲动，“你知道吗，就翻个身。”
Instead of getting up because I know it's important, it's like, "Just roll over. Whatever. It doesn't mean that much. You don't need this. It's not that important. You don't want it."
而不是因为我知道它很重要而起床，它就像，“翻身吧。随便吧。这意义不大。你不需要这个。它没那么重要。你不想要它。”
And I'll oversleep, or I'll be late, or won't show up, something like that. It happens a lot, especially for things that could potentially benefit me. Because some part of me is either "this is stupid" or "you don't deserve it" or something. And I'm pretty sure that's depression.
我会睡过头，或者迟到，或者不出现，诸如此类。这经常发生，特别是对于那些可能对我有利的事情。因为我的一部分要么是“这很蠢”，要么是“你不配”什么的。我很确定那是抑郁。
For all the potential of his big brain, Ryan had the feeling that life was slipping him by. And when he became a father in his 30s, the question of lost potential became moot. He needed money to live and to provide, so he did all sorts of jobs-- airport security worker, warehouse grunt, package handler, office clerk.
拥有大脑袋的所有潜能，瑞安觉得生活正从他身边溜走。当他在30多岁成为父亲时，丢失潜能的问题就变得无关紧要了。他需要钱来生活和供养，所以他做了各种工作——机场安保员、仓库搬运工、包裹搬运工、办公室职员。
Piano mover, water ice guy, worked at UPS, was a cashier, was a bouncer, was a street sweeper for a couple of weeks. You got to do what you got to do, right?
钢琴搬运工、水冰哥、在UPS工作过、做过收银员、保镖，做了几周的扫街工。你必须做你必须做的事，对吧？
But then in January 2021, Ryan got sick with COVID. He had it really bad, and was in hospital for three weeks. He had to be given oxygen to stay alive. And he still has the photo of his saturated lungs, given to him by his doctor as a reminder of how close he came to death.
但后来在2021年1月，瑞安得了新冠。他病得很重，在医院住了三周。他不得不被吸氧以维持生命。他仍然保留着医生给他的饱和肺部照片，作为对他离死亡有多近的提醒。
When he was discharged, he was a wreck. His knee gave out and he got diabetes. More than 20 years of the working grind seemed to catch up to him all at once.
当他出院时，他是一个残骸。他的膝盖不行了，他还得了糖尿病。20多年来的工作压力似乎一下子追上了他。
I felt in the moment like I'd wasted my life thus far. I hadn't done anything I wanted to do. I hadn't gone anywhere that I wanted to go. I started feeling like maybe I didn't have a huge amount of time left.
那一刻我觉得我浪费了自己的一生。我没做过任何我想做的事。我没去过任何我想去的地方。我开始觉得也许我没有多少时间了。
My dad died young. His dad died young. I didn't want to have to do that to my kid. I found my dad dead. I thought, if you're going to have a memory of me, have a good one.
我父亲死得早。他父亲死得早。我不想对我孩子那样。我发现我父亲死了。我想，如果你要对我有一个记忆，那就留一个好的。
Getting COVID and surviving it was, in Ryan's own words, "a rockfall that turned into a landslide." It made him want to get out of his old habit of minimizing himself, this urge to snatch defeats from the jaws of victory.
得新冠并存活下来，用瑞安自己的话说，是“变成山崩的岩崩”。它让他想要摆脱贬低自己的旧习惯，这种从胜利的口中抢夺失败的冲动。
That's when he got the call from Jeopardy. He'd taken the online test on a whim. And now, Ryan thought, this could be the thing he'd been hoping would come along to shake things up.
就在那时他接到了《危险边缘》的电话。他是一时兴起参加的在线测试。现在，瑞安想，这可能是他一直希望出现的改变现状的事情。
That question I'd had about his journey to Jeopardy, it turns out the literal trip was a joint effort. He had about $200 to spare that month, and he had to make his own way to California. So he turned to his mom and his friends. He borrowed his mother's luggage and packed some black trousers plus two shirts-- one he'd bought himself, and the other bought by his mom.
对于他去《危险边缘》的旅程我有的那个问题，原来那次字面意义上的旅行是一次共同努力。那个月他只有大约200美元的闲钱，他必须自己去加利福尼亚。所以他求助于他的妈妈和朋友。他借了妈妈的行李箱，塞进了一些黑色长裤加上两件衬衫——一件是他自己买的，另一件是他妈妈买的。
Remember how he made the decision as a teenager to hide his light under a bushel so he could be more normal? Now he was making another decision-- this time the guy whose tendency was to downplay his intelligence and his abilities was not going to get in his own way.
还记得他少年时做出的决定，隐藏自己的光芒以变得更正常吗？现在他又做了一个决定——这次，那个倾向于贬低自己智慧和能力的人不会再阻碍自己了。
The work was on me where I had to first acknowledge that I wanted it, give myself permission to want it. And say, OK, we're going to do this thing and we're going to do it right and we're not going to screw it up.
工作在于我，我首先必须承认我想要它，给自己权限去想要它。并说，好的，我们要去做这件事，我们要把它做好，我们不会把它搞砸。
He got on the plane to California. He'd never been off the east coast in his life. He was determined to enjoy himself. And he told himself, no expectations. Unlike some other wannabe winners, he did no tutorials on technique, no arduous studying.
他坐飞机去了加利福尼亚。他一生中从未走出过东海岸。他决心享受自己。他告诉自己，不要有期望。不像其他一些想赢的人，他没有做任何技术教程，没有艰苦的学习。
These are people that all year long they study, buying books on the buzzer technique and all that. When I've found out that people did that, [LAUGHS] I felt like, oh, should I have studied? I guess, maybe.
这些人一年到头都在学习，购买关于蜂鸣器技术的书，所有这些。当我发现人们这样做时，[笑] 我觉得，哦，我应该学习吗？我想，也许吧。
You didn't pick up "The Big Book of Jeopardy Questions?"
你没捡起《危险边缘问题大全》？
I didn't have time. I was working. I was working up until right before I left.
我没时间。我在工作。我一直工作到离开前。
On the day of his first game Ryan felt overwhelmed, but he worked through it. He let himself cry, which was an effective release valve for some of the emotional turmoil he was feeling. And then he pumped himself up with some music. Once he felt more in control, he headed to the studio to the show he'd watched since he was a little boy in Philly.
瑞安参加第一场比赛的那天感到不知所措，但他克服了。他让自己哭了出来，这是对他所感到的情感动荡的一种有效的释放阀。然后他用音乐振作自己。一旦他感觉更掌控局势，他就前往摄影棚，去他从费城还是个小男孩时就看的那个节目。
Felt like hallowed ground-- Jeopardy, the stage. When you get up there, it looks exactly like when Luke fought Vader on Bespin in "The Empire Strikes Back," the lighting.
感觉像是圣地——《危险边缘》，那个舞台。当你站在上面时，它看起来就像卢克在《帝国反击战》中与维达在贝斯平战斗时那样，灯光效果。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
The red stair and then the blue background, that was the first thing I noticed when I got up there. I was like, oh, my god! Really felt like something, man.
红色楼梯然后是蓝色背景，那是我站在上面时注意到的第一件事。我当时想，噢，天哪！真的感觉像是有什么东西，伙计。
--Sawyer and Tyrion Lannister. Ryan?
——索耶和提利昂·兰尼斯特。瑞安？
Who is Peter Dinklage?
彼得·丁拉基是谁？
Yes, and you just ran that category.
是的，你刚刚跑完了那个分类。
So that was a somewhat nerdy beginning of his 16-game streak. He puts the success down to two things-- knowing stuff and staying calm under pressure.
所以这是他16连胜的一个书呆子式的开始。他把成功归功于两件事——知道东西和在压力下保持冷静。
Ryan?
瑞安？
Who was Jesse Owens?
杰西·欧文斯是谁？
Correct.
正确。
In game mode, Ryan's demeanor was testament to the decision he'd made to go out there and just have fun. He laughed at himself when he flubbed the Daily Double, or realized he had bet too low on an easy answer. He delivered his cute little anecdotes in the "getting to know you" segments. But once the game was won, that easy grace was gone.
在比赛模式中，瑞安的举止证明了他为了去那里玩得开心而做出的决定。他会因为在每日双倍题中犯错或意识到自己对一个简单答案押注太低而嘲笑自己。他在“认识你”片段中讲述了他可爱的小轶事。但一旦比赛获胜，那种轻松的优雅就消失了。
Congratulations, you are our Jeopardy champion. Another fantastic week for Ryan Long.
祝贺你，你是我们的《危险边缘》冠军。瑞安·朗又度过了精彩的一周。
Instead, when his new total winnings were announced, he'd do that thing I loved. The head duck, and looking like he wanted the ground to swallow him up.
相反，当宣布他新的总奖金时，他会做那个我喜欢的动作。低头，看起来就像想让地把他吞掉。
I couldn't believe it I heard it every time.
我无法相信我每次都听到它。
Every time?
每次？
Every time I heard it, I was like, this-- nah. I don't think I could-- that didn't happen to me, [LAUGHS] you know?
每次我听到它，我就想，这——不。我不认为我能——那没发生在我身上，[笑] 你知道吗？
So I guess Ryan and I met on the very first day. Well, my only day of taping on Jeopardy, and Ryan's second day, I guess it was?
所以我猜我和瑞安在第一天就见了面。嗯，我参加《危险边缘》录制的一天，也是瑞安的第二天，我猜是？
That's Brad Pearson. He was a challenger of Ryan's, also a Philly local. The two of them stayed friends after the show. They even had a little watch party at Brad's house the night his episode aired.
那是布拉德·皮尔逊。他是瑞安的挑战者，也是费城本地人。他们两人在节目后成了朋友。在这一集播出当晚，他们甚至在布拉德家举办了一个小型的观看派对。
Over cheesesteaks, he told us about playing against Ryan in his fifth game. Contestants get to watch preceding games before they tape theirs. And all eyes were on Ryan, the returning champ, game after game. Brad was sitting with Tony, another of the pool of challengers.
吃着奶酪牛排，他告诉我们关于在第五场比赛中与瑞安对垒的情况。选手在录制前会观看之前的比赛。所有的目光都集中在瑞安身上，卫冕冠军，一场又一场。布拉德和挑战者池里的另一个人托尼坐在一起。
As the day progressed, Tony turns to me at one point during the third game, and he goes, "He's only getting stronger!"
随着一天进展，托尼在第三场比赛中有一次转向我说，他说，“他越来越强了！”
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
Brad noted the same thing I did-- that Ryan was a real all-rounder, banging out answers to everything from biblical locations, to the alumni of Saturday Night Live.
布拉德注意到了我和一样的事情——瑞安是一个真正的全能选手，对从圣经地点到《周六夜现场》校友的一切问题都能回答出来。
When I think of Ryan as a player, the thing is that you find certain people that are good at some really specific stuff. But Ryan's knowledge is so across the board, and also does really good on things that--
当我想到瑞安作为一名选手时，问题在于你会发现有些人擅长一些非常具体的东西。但瑞安的知识非常全面，而且在那些事情上也做得很好——
I got to go take a walk.
我得出去走走。
This is going to sound bad, but--
这听起来会很糟糕，但是——
Ryan actually moved away when Brad was talking about him so admiringly. It's like the glare of praise was too bright for his eyes. He couldn't look directly at it. He did something similar when his mom bragged about him, and again when his friend Mari, who we also met, mentioned how great of a guy he was.
当布拉德如此赞赏地谈论他时，瑞安实际上走开了。就像赞美的刺眼光芒对他来说太亮了。他无法直视。当他妈妈吹嘘他，以及当我们见到的另一个朋友马里提到他是一个多么棒的人时，他也做了类似的动作。
His face got all scrunched up, like it physically pained him to hear. But even so, over the course of his games, he beat contestants with far more impressive on-paper CVs. Even after winning, he knew that he wasn't seen as a typical Jeopardy winner.
他的脸缩成一团，好像听到这些让他身体上感到痛苦。但即便如此，在他比赛的过程中，他击败了那些纸面上履历令人印象深刻得多的选手。即使在获胜后，他也知道他没被视为典型的《危险边缘》赢家。
I don't look smart, whatever that means. I look like a bruiser.
我不看起来聪明，不管那意味着什么。我看起来像个打手。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
And people underestimate me a lot. I know I'm kind of smart. I know what I can do. There was a little tiny bit of class satisfaction. I don't mind admitting it--
人们经常低估我。我知道我有点聪明。我知道我能做什么。有一点点阶级满足感。我不介意承认这一点——
Yeah?
是吗？
--that I came in and beat all these wonderful people. People like my mom, people like me, we've always watched the show. We've just never been represented on the show before, I guess you could say. But we're out here.
——我进来击败了所有这些了不起的人。像我妈妈那样的人，像我那样的人，我们一直都在看这个节目。我猜你可以说，之前我们从来没在节目中被代表过。但我们在这儿。
Ryan's tweet thread about the box, he'd written that he didn't really believe a person could break out of the box. But, he added, I feel like this thing that just happened is proof that you can. And I wondered what he'd found outside of the box since he had managed to get out.
瑞安关于盒子的推文串，他写道他真的不相信一个人能跳出那个盒子。但，他补充说，我觉得刚刚发生的事情证明你可以。我想知道自从他成功跳出来后，他在盒子外面发现了什么。
Returning to Philly, it was hard for Ryan to know how to act. His episodes wouldn't be on television for another few weeks. It was like he had to pretend something monumental hadn't just happened to him.
回到费城，瑞安很难知道该怎么做。他的节目在接下来的几周内不会在电视上播出。就像他必须假装什么重大事件没发生在他身上一样。
There's no way to talk about Ryan's time on the show without talking about the money he won. $299,400 is quite the windfall. He no longer works as a rideshare driver, having paid off his old car and bought this new truck.
谈论瑞安在节目上的时间，没法不谈论他赢的钱。299,400美元可是一笔意外之财。他不再当拼车司机了，付清了旧车的钱，买了这辆新卡车。
On the advice of his mom, he met up with a couple of people from a community improvement group for advice about what to do with this new earnings. Their advice was that he prioritize himself first, a concept that was completely foreign to him, and set up a chain reaction of self improvements.
在他妈妈的建议下，他见了社区改善小组的几个人，咨询如何处理这笔新收入。他们的建议是他优先考虑自己，这个概念对他来说完全陌生，并引发了一系列自我提升的连锁反应。
I wasn't a very reflective person, or anything like that, and I neglected myself for about 30 years. So I figured now is the time. I have a rare chance, which it seems like a lot of Americans don't have anymore. Because I got time to improve myself, take a real good look at myself, you know?
我不是一个很善于反思的人，诸如此类，我忽视了自己大约30年。所以我想现在是时候了。我有一个难得的机会，这看起来很多美国人都没有了。因为我有时间提升自己，好好审视自己，你知道吗？
Ryan started working out again. He got himself a therapist. He went digging in his family tree and found a book written by his third-time great grandfather, a staunch Methodist abolitionist. And he bought movies.
瑞安又开始锻炼了。他给自己找了个治疗师。他去挖掘家族树，发现了他第三代曾祖父写的书，一位坚定的卫理公会废奴主义者。他还买了电影。
I love, love, love films. I'll buy the extra special deluxe, whatever, whatever, if I can. So every July, The Criterion sale is 50% off, and every year something happens and I can't afford to go. And I was like, I'm going this year. [SNAPS] Going!
我爱、爱、爱电影。如果可以，我会买超特别豪华版。所以每年七月，标准收藏（Criterion）销售半价，每年都会发生点什么，我买不起。我当时想，我今年要去。[响指] 要去！
[LAUGHS] What's the first one you're going to watch, do you reckon?
[笑] 你认为你要看的第一部是什么？
Oh, you know, I think I'm going to watch Raging Bull. I heard The Criterion was coming out with the 4K, I was like, oh, my god, yes! It's so great. It's a great movie-- difficult to watch though.
哦，你知道，我想我要看《愤怒的公牛》。我听说标准收藏要出4K版，我当时想，噢，天哪，是的！太棒了。这是一部伟大的电影——不过很难看。
Horrible to watch--
很难看——
Yeah.
是的。
--in places.
——在某些地方。
Difficult, but it's also difficult because every man can recognize a part of himself in Jake LaMotta-- like some small part, some of us more than others. But we all have that ugly competitive sort of thing inside us, however small, or that ugly, self-loathing type beast.
很难，但也因为每个男人都可以在杰克·拉莫塔身上认出自己的一部分——比如某些小部分，我们有些人比别人多。但我们内心都有那种丑陋的竞争性的东西，不管有多小，或者那种丑陋的、自我厌恶的野兽。
Getting to finally buy Criterion movies, working on his LaMotta style self-loathing, spending hours researching family history, the whole "Project Ryan," it's being facilitated by the most precious commodity his Jeopardy run brought him.
终于可以买标准收藏电影，研究拉莫塔式的自我厌恶，花几个小时研究家庭历史，整个“瑞安计划”，正被《危险边缘》带来的最珍贵的商品所促进。
So, clearly, Jeopardy changed your life. So what is your life now?
那么，显然，《危险边缘》改变了你的生活。那么你现在的生活是什么？
It allowed me the opportunity to have time to do this, which I wouldn't have had time to do anyway.
它给了我机会拥有时间去做这件事，这是我无论如何都没时间做的。
What's this?
什么是这？
It-- examine myself, I guess. Just everything before, looking where I come from and what makes me tick. It's a valuable thing. I think everybody needs to do it, but not everybody has time to do it.
审视我自己，我猜。之前发生的一切，看看我来自哪里以及是什么驱动了我。这是一件宝贵的事情。我觉得每个人都需要这样做，但不是每个人都有时间这样做。
So that's the biggest post-Jeopardy change is just an abundance of time for you now?
所以《危险边缘》后最大的变化只是现在你拥有了大量时间？
Yeah. That's the most valuable thing that I got out of this.
是的。这是我从中得到的最大的宝藏。
Not the money?
不是钱？
Well, the money made the time possible. They say money can't buy happiness, but it buys everything that makes you happy-- even time.
好吧，钱使时间成为可能。人们说钱买不到幸福，但它买到了所有让你快乐的东西——甚至是时间。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
I had come to Philly to talk to Ryan about navigating outside expectations as they crashed up against what he thought about himself, and I got that. But I also got this accidental reflection on American capitalism, and how so many of us are served so poorly by the way life is currently set up as all work and no time. Jeopardy provided a very specific Ryan-shaped escape hatch. It gave him the space to stare into that crack between realities, and fish out all the elements of what his life could be.
我来费城和瑞安谈论在外部期望与他对自己看法碰撞时的应对，我得到了答案。但我也得到了关于美国资本主义的意外反思，以及我们中有多少人被生活目前设置成全工作没时间的方式服务得如此糟糕。 《危险边缘》提供了一个非常具体的瑞安形状的逃生舱。它给了他盯着现实之间裂缝的机会，并钓出他生活可能是什么样的所有元素。
Bim Adewunmi is one of the producers of our show.
比姆·阿德温米是我们节目的制作人之一。
Our program was produced today by Lilly Sullivan. People who put together our show include Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Michal Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Cassie Howley, Chana Joffe-Walt, Valerie Kipnis, Tobin Low, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Laura Starecheski, Christopher Swetala, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu.
我们节目今天由莉莉·沙利文制作。组建我们节目的人包括比姆·阿德温米、艾尔娜·贝克、佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、米哈尔·科米特、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德、凯西·豪利、查娜·乔菲-沃尔特、瓦莱丽·基普尼斯、托宾·洛、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、阿丽莎·希普、劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、玛丽莎·罗伯逊-泰克斯特、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。
Our managing editor, Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Nathan Rott, Kateryna Malofieieva, Jessica Huseman, Troy Harvard, Stacey Behymer, Lizzy Berryman, Rachel VanLandingham, Jake Perlman and Jacob Rockey.
我们的执行编辑，莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。今天特别感谢内森·罗特、卡特琳娜·马洛菲耶娃、杰西卡·胡斯曼、特洛伊·哈佛、斯泰西·贝希默、利齐·贝里曼、瑞秋·范兰丁厄姆、杰克·珀尔曼和雅各布·罗基。
Our website, where you can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free during your holiday travel, and where we have merch for all your gift giving needs, including new t-shirts, sweatshirts, and onesies, posters, temporary tattoos. Where does all this magic happen? ThisAmericanLife.org.
我们的网站，在那里你可以流媒体播放我们超过700集的档案，在你的节日旅行中完全免费，我们有适合你所有礼品需求的周边产品，包括新T恤、运动衫和连体衣、海报、临时纹身。这一切魔法在哪里发生？ThisAmericanLife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, he has always wanted that job at NASA-- you know the one doing the countdown when they launch a rocket? But I don't know, I don't think he's got the right stuff.
《美国生活》由公共广播交易所PRX分发给公共广播电台。感谢一如既往的节目联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他一直想在NASA找那份工作——你知道做发射火箭倒计时那份？但我不知道，我不认为他有合适的素质。
Three, two, one?
三，二，一？
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。